no one is smart enough to be a hundred
percent wrong right so what that means
is that everybody is holding some piece
of a truth and they're also partial so
everything is true but partial so when
we begin to look at the world with a
hermeneutic of generosity we interpret
the world with a generous spirit we
begin to say oh well there must be some
truth in that even if there's a lot of
it that might be partial there's
something true there and we begin to
look at the world with this generous
spirit we see oh everything actually has
something to offer something to
contribute and that to me is the gift of
an integral theory is that we begin to
see a much more robust and rich and
pluralistic experience of reality that
also is a fun folding throughout time in
a really incredible way that can benefit
all of us and the planet and beyond to
me that's super exciting
so north-south-east-west this is the the
global wisdom tradition that's unfolding
is an integration of all these streams
into one great human tradition
[Applause]